du thé à la menthe décliné en plusieurs
recettes c'est l'idée qu'a eue zakaria
créer la première maison de thé à la
menthe au monde dans le berry avec déjà
huit versions à son actif il souhaite en
produire entre 50 et 100 d'ici une
dizaine d'années on a découvert qu'il
existe une 1000 variétés demande dans le
monde du 3000 difficulté différents dans
le monde et donc on s'est dit si on
s'amusait à faire de l'association entre
ces différentes mende ces différentes et
et bien on peut créer des compositions
de thé à la menthe une nouvelle
génération à l'origine c'est une
histoire familiale une promesse faite à
sa maman décédée en 2015 alors forcément
le tout premier thé créé devait rendre
hommage c'est beaucoup d'émotions tous à
20 c
en 30 ans jouait les gens étaient
présents lorsque je revenais en berry
maman nous attendait une manière
traditionnelle dans le speed ait été
marocaine avec un thé à la menthe de
jour comme de nuit c'est exceptionnel et
à chaque fois lorsqu'on se rencontrer
autour de cet élément et 8 et familiale
des mamans ponte est tellement bon du
helmand dans le monde entier hier matin
sur la ville et puis j'ai dit à mon
petit monde on a créé une marque de
callamand hommage à moulins wima c'est
comme ça que mes enfants appelé leur
grand mère qui faisait le meilleur tu
est l'amante du berry à base de thé vert
ou de thé noir avec ou sans agrumes ou
encore parfumé à la rose le thé à la
menthe made in der y bouscule les
papilles ce thé à la menthe et est
extraordinaire en fait c'est subtil
c'est ses fins et vraiment pas besoin de
sucre dans le thé on sent les arômes
cependant il est déjà sucre et les
ingrédients utilisés sont tous naturels
et proviennent pour l'instant du monde
entier mais à terme macharia souhait
très cultivé ça proprement biologique
dans le monde il n'y a pas suffisamment
de monde végétal
disponibles par rapport à la
consommation qu'on en fait dans
différentes industries agroalimentaires
mais également pharmaceutique et et
autres et donc depuis deux ans on
travaille à l'idée d'avoir notre menti
en berry donc ici vous pouvez voir sur
un petit espace 5 plantations qui ont
été faites donc expérimental le 21 mai
prochain à kariat souhaite créer le
premier championnat du thé à la menthe à
rosières avec préparation et dégustation
pour faire du berry à hollywood ou thé à
la menthe